11. drag it's the drive and kick butler
left open
got it talking about into october butler
vicious jimmy butler to the rim for the
dump
seven his first three-pointer of the
night for the bucks
butler taking on contact and then again
into the paint and draw the foul which
he does
so you can finish that play
butler the little hesitation boy that
was a thing of beauty by butler
he's got 27 points to lead all scorers
strength to finish jimmy butler a little
hesitation will move
hits the floater over the top last
basketball middleton his first points by
the way since the eight minute mark of
the third quarter
butler sizes him up and hits
well to add a bio and getting cuts
butler deep three and he buries it
six to shoot butler sizes up hill and he
hits again
jimmy butler just going one on one and
getting it up over the top of a smaller
defender
huge bucket no traps no fouls
just try to get a stop there's still a
lot of time butler again
he has been magnificent me butler
tying his career play-off high with 36
points
that's the furthest thing from his mind
here is butler inside and he just keeps
on coming
he has brought this buck's defense to
its knees
in the second half and here he is again
butler
middleton just bear hugs him